il primo organo che si vede è il cuore
non è il cervello io non me l'aspettavo
forse una cosa che ci dimentichiamo nel
corso della vita
ma questo all'ecografia al terzo mese al
quinto mese quella che si chiama la
morfologica la poesia è già finita
l'ecografista si muove su un'immagine
che tu non capisci dice e il cervelletto
vediamo se c'è sì c'è il cervelletto e
il femore vediamo se lungo giusto sia
lungo giusto è io mi dico come
cervelletto ma perché non dovrebbe
esserci il cervelletto e poi a cosa
serve se non ci fosse il femore quanto
deve essere lungo e lui va avanti ormai
è molto più avanti l'elenco degli organi
ecco si nasce così misurati calibrati
verificati rispetto dei parametri
standard attesi si nasce già con un voto
cell indice di apgar alla nascita è una
sintesi di parametri di salute che
qualche modo dice in decimi come voti a
scuola
quante sanno tuo figlio dal minuto 0
così questo è solo il trailer le
ecografie che fai sono soli fair l di un
film che farai che vedrai dopo perché
appena nasce deve misurare di quanti g
crescioni settimane sono 30 40 50 non di
più il tuo figlio non sta fermo e
misurano tu su una bilancio un bambino
che si muove essi sono 40 50 è difficile
perché oscilla e se sono di meno
ti viene il panico perché forse non
mangia abbastanza non ha il latte che
serve e poi deve crescere di thor
centimetri e c'è una curva che vedi ogni
volta che vai dal pediatra della curva
di crescita della popolazione media e
tuo figlio è lì che balla sopra sotto
durata e e se sopra c'è l'orgoglio di
papà di mamma mio figlio sopra la media
e se sotto nota c'è un po più la
vergogna finché a un certo punto può
darsi che scivoli al decimo percentile
allora lì c'è il panico c'è il panico
del fatto che forse devi fare le cure
ormonali forse non sta crescendo come
dovrebbe forse qualcosa non va mai fatto
a che tuo figlio non lo guardi lo
controlli che è molto diverso allora con
questa ansia di da genitore addosso fai
tutto il possibile allora giostrine
palestrine stimoli di ogni tipo come se
la natura non bastasse come se non
potesse fare il suo corso come se la
realtà non fosse abbastanza curiosa da
osservare e va a inseguire a cercare le
cose giuste quindi leggi sulle scatole
chiede negozianti la cosa giusta per un
bambino di trani anzi una bambina e
tranne il libro giusto la scatola giusta
ma tu non è che stai guardando lui o lei
se guardando la scatola e lo chiede al
negoziante che cosa prende perché c'è
già il mercato addosso perché il mercato
via 6 del mercato entrato in scena il
primo giorno almeno nella nostra
presenza perché quando è nato pietro al
canto c'era già il parco la cremina la
pomatina la spazzolina pietro era nato
era già un nuovo consumatore
e poi non ti molla il mercato lo sanno
bene gli psicologi del marketing a due
linguaggi
uno è quello che usa quei bambini coi
ragazzi ed è un linguaggio che tu non
capisci completamente perché fatto di
colori accesi di forma e studiate
ovviamente e poi di personaggi che sono
quelli dei cartoni riff che un certo
punto sono dappertutto sono sui
tovaglioli nei piattini conte anni
stampati sulle quote su su gli zainetti
quaderni diari sono ovunque tanto che
trovarli senza un problema e ti sembra
che tuo figlio li vuole ma non li vuole
lui lui quel momento non sta desiderano
neanche sta facendo i capricci sta
eseguendo un compito perché il mercato
che desidera per lui
lui sta eseguendo quel compito e tu
intanto si è impegnato in altro perché
il messaggio per te diverso il codice
diverso il tuo codice quello stampato
sulle istruzioni delle confezioni
dove c'è scritto questa cosa è adatta
per qui dentro ci sono le vitamine
questo fa bene per questo per
quell'altro perché gli psicologi del
marketing lo sanno che tu devi sentirti
un bravo genitore ed è questo il
messaggio che ti ha rivolto in questo
assedio normativo la scuola ci mette del
suo quando pietro è entrato alla scuola
materna eravamo un po in ritardo
rispetto all'inserimento qualche giorno
dopo arriviamo e il colpo è già formato
i bambini stanno cantando con
l'insegnante in coro una canzone con
libro delle canzoni dell'insegnante
allora pietro per inserirsi dice ma
posso cantare la canzone della montagna
e canta la sua canzone pensa che questo
sia la chiave e si inventa questa
canzone l'insegnante guarda il quaderno
dice no scusa non c'è la canzone la
montagna non la possiamo cantare nella
materna ci sono appesi tutte quelle
sagome già fatte che tu devi colorare
dentro guai uscire fuori uso i colori
giusti se usi se usi colori scuri viole
nero l'insegnante pt c'è qualcosa che
non va
margherita sette anni ci chiede a
colazione ma quanti sono sessanta
secondi e non glielo facciamo vedere ma
e tallona l'orologio un bambino di 7
anni non deve avere l'orologio ma cosa
succedeva gli dramma perché margherita
hai bisogno di saperla e domani ci han
invalsi che va in scena in seconda
elementare che è un test a tempo e da
quel momento per margherite tempo va al
contrario anziché scorrere come nella
non è nella natura come nella sua vita
va al contrario come fabbrica al lavoro
e come qui e da lì le premium ansia
tremenda una sua compagna di classe
viene dalla style anche allora si
assenta qualche giorno per andare nel
paese d'origine della famiglia quando
torna
l'insegnante chiede ma scusa dove sia
stata questi giorni dice sono stati se
la anche il paese dei miei genitori
e l'insegnante le dice sa bene adesso
mettiti in pari con i compiti
mettiti in parco i compiti ma qui
l'insegnante la vista quella bambina o
asfar scritto su di lei l'allieva che
doveva essere quel giorno la lezione la
doveva tenere quella bambina è questo
che succede noi in realtà ai bambini
ragazzi non li vediamo cieli guardiamo
non per quello che sono
che fanno ma per quello che ancora non
solo non fanno non hanno cioè
sostanzialmente misuriamo la loro
distanza fra la nostra aspettativa il
nostro stando alla nostra misura e
quello che sono ma che non ci basta e la
loro vita va avanti fino al 16 20 anni
quando incontro i ragazzi che incontro
mi faccio ricerca che intervisto con cui
facciamo insieme le cose e loro mi
dicono ma tutti questi test queste
verifiche queste prove queste casti a
parte in italia in vista di cosa qual
era il premio qual era il traguardo di
questa rincorsa e poi ti dicono ma
santino non so in realtà cosa mi piace
ho sempre fatto quello che dovevo e poi
non mi sento abbastanza forse non sono
adeguata forse non ce la fa o forse non
riuscirò non lo so non so cosa sceglie
la paura del futuro
ma com'è possibile nel momento del
nell'età del della potenza dell'eros del
desiderio aver paura delle altre del
futuro ma come abbiamo potuto portare
una generazione a quel punto anziché
convocarla nella realtà l'abbiamo tenuta
in esilio in cattività anziché dare i
compiti di realtà e responsabilità
questo dico sostanzialmente una follia
che non possiamo più permetterci per il
semplice motivo che ci stiamo
dimenticando che noi quando emigravamo
emigravamo ragazzi e un'intera famiglia
scommetteva sui ragazzi che partivano
per ritrovare l'economia la felicità gli
adulti scommettevano sui ragazzi ci
stiamo dimenticando che il novecento è
stato fatto di idee e di scoperte di
giovani che avevano fi 20 30 anni fa i
20 30
einstein aveva 26 anni quando ha scritto
l'articolo famoso sulla relatività
quindi non era quel vecchio bianco quei
baffoni no era un giovane di 26 anni ci
stiamo dimenticando che le grandi
aziende degli anni 2000 sono state fatte
da ragazzi che abbiamo fa i 18 e 25 anni
ora questo non è il migliore dei mondi
possibili
forse ce lo dobbiamo dire e proprio
perché non è il migliore dei mondi
possibili e lo dobbiamo raccontare così
dobbiamo provare a trovare dei varchi
per far entrare ragazzi dobbiamo
assumerci il compito del suo
miglioramento è da lì che si entra
perché se il mondo esatto museificato no
no no entry non c'è posto per te ed è
quello che sentono i ragazzi che non si
sentono utili perché non c'è posto non
sono previsti è tutto già occupato un po
come questo teatro allora da dove entri
se tutte già predisposte tutto già
pronto
non solo realtà è cambiata tantissimo in
questi anni e la mia base esperienziale
non conta nulla rispetto a quella che ha
un ragazzo avrà un ragazzo io non sono
la misura dei miei figli e gli adulti
presenti non sono la misura dei ragazzi
presenti
parlo per me io ho fatto un liceo che ha
cambiato completamente un'università che
è cambiata completamente
ho fatto l'obiezione di coscienza al
servizio militare
facendo un servizio civile di 20 mesi
nulla di tutto questo esiste
ho cercato lavoro con le pagine gialle
sono andato a guardare società di
ricerca o mandato sei lettere ho trovato
lavoro
potrò mai dire questo ragazzo ho parlato
una lingua ho vissuto in una città
ho fatto un solo mestiere anche questo
probabilmente non è più la misura
evidentemente dei ragazzi che ho di
fronte
questa generazione che abbiamo di fronte
molti sono presenti non debbano essere
formati come allievi che devono eseguire
dei compiti per scritti perché c'è un
manuale che valeva ieri e vale oggi
devono essere formati come pioniere
informarsi come pioniere completamente
diverso vuol dire che devi spostare la
frontiera della conoscenza
vuoi dire che devi studiare devi anche
imparare a disimparare come diceva
grigioni mezzo quindi sostanzialmente a
ricostruire continuamente le regole
guidare vuol dire che ti avesse ha
formato con domande non allenato a
rispondere come succede a scuola e
queste domande devono essere domande
legittime non illegittime che sono
quelli che ci sono a scuola
all'università che sono quelle dove chi
fa la domanda se la risposta è che
risponde sa di dover dare la risposta
che nella testa di chi domanda se si è
allenato così non ti pensi portatori di
alcun sapere di alcuna scoperta di
alcuna possibilità di ingresso nella
realtà perché tutto è già scritto già
fatto
un giorno siamo al mare pietro a 10 11
anni e mi dice papà voglio diventare
ricco noi non siamo ricchi e io non so
come prenderla mi viene in mente questo
bello così può esser generoso e lui mi
dice no non intendevo questo e allora
cerco di riprendere un altro modo e dico
che è pietro allora per diventare ricco
devi trovare qualcosa che sia la
soluzione un problema comune una
risposta che risponde in qualche modo a
un'esigenza collettiva e quindi forse
può avere successo
lui si guarda attorno e dice potremmo
prendere potabile quest'acqua l'acqua
del mare
c'eravamo questa è la sfida di cui parlo
cercare di assumersi compiti di realtà
qualcosa che davvero urge da fuori e
provare a cercare soluzioni quei ragazzi
a questo faccio gruppi interdisciplinari
dove mette semi pensiero divergente di
bambini l'energia dei ragazzi la
maturità degli adulti insieme li
immaginiamo quartiere biblioteche scuole
per capire cosa si può fare spegniamo la
luce
rompiamo il ricatto del presente perché
il real è molto più della realtà il
presente non è repertorio del possibile
e immaginiamo cos'altro si può fare in
un luogo in un lavoro che appena fatto
chiesto ai ragazzi addirittura questo
sentite abbiamo i negozianti residenti a
voi chiedo di fare gli alberi fate i
portavoce della natura perché ci serve
capire qualunque che fa cosa faremo in
questo quartiere ci serve avere
l'orizzonte lungo della natura e siete
gli unici che possono incarnare la
natura e lo fanno e sono contentissimo
di questo sto parlando
noi in realtà questa cosa come dire di
mettersi insieme di collabora insieme la
facciamo in italia ma la facciamo una
sola volta quando ci sono le grandi
emergenze quando ci sono i terremoti le
alluvioni
quando avvengono quelle cose siamo uno
accanto all'altro e non ci chiediamo chi
è quello lì non è che lo misuriamo
rispetto
abbiamo un compito di realtà urgente lo
facciamo assieme e funziona
in quella circostanza e spesso guardiamo
i ragazzi e li chiamiamo il giorno dopo
gli angeli del fango ci accorgiamo di
loro sono in quella circostanza e loro
non sono molto contenti e hanno ragione
ecco di questo parlo di compiti di
realtà in fondo e fare quello che hannah
arendt chiamava politica la politica non
è occuparci gli uni degli altri ma
occuparci insieme del mondo ogni giorno
grazie
[Applauso]